how are you guys doing how are you guys
doing
good really good how are you doing uh so
i want to start with um
you've heard me say this before but i
think mosul is so
f and well done i rewatched it last
night
and i can't recommend the movie enough
it is just really
fantastic um this is matthew's
feature directorial debut there's a lot
of things that this movie is doing that
are not the norm
when did you guys think oh yeah he can
actually handle this material
matt is one of the most accomplished
screenwriters in the business we've been
huge fans of his for years
and um we knew we fell in love with the
the article the origin the article that
this is based on luke mogelson wrote an
article for the new yorker fantastic
piece of journalism
where he embedded himself with uh the
swat team
in mosul for six months and documented
their experiences
and we knew it was going to be a
difficult story to translate so we
needed to approach somebody of matt's
caliber we did
and matt cracked a very difficult story
in such a way
it was basically the way matt took to
the story
and sort of understood how to wrangle it
in a way that we hadn't imagined
he it felt like he had a lot of
ownership creative ownership of the
movie because of that
and that i think is what inspired us to
to ask him to direct
i'll ask you joe um one of the things
that i think is really
um great about this is that it is uh
arab-speaking people that are being
depicted as
heroes as family people and not just
terrorists and the stereotypical kind of
thing that a lot of american audiences
in the world are exposed to
can you sort of talk about that aspect
it's a critical aspect i mean that
is what you know that as ant said when
we read that article i think it was the
it was it was perhaps the best piece of
journalism we've ever read because it
created
such a point of view such a powerful
point of view
um and a part of the world that that you
know we
we don't think about much as americans
and we don't have access to
the true stories and the real stories
that happen they only see
um our our side of it uh and um
you know i think we have to remember in
media
how powerful a tool it is
and how it can alter and affect the way
that people
think about things and it's uh it's
critically important
that we use that tool for positive
representation
to tell um um stories that uh
that you know might not get told uh
otherwise and i think as artists running
a company
it's also our responsibility to um to
find those stories and to help them get
told um
and uh and i think matt and the cast all
did an incredible job
of uh of you know telling this in the
most realistic
uh and uh and you know human
with the most human truth that you
possibly could
uh and we think it's a beautiful film as
well uh one of the things about this
is that um it's an arabic cast
speaking all arabic language there's no
americans in this at
during the development process even
though you guys run agbo
was anyone along the way saying yeah is
this
really what you know what i mean because
this is not the norm of what a lot of
people want to
produce early in their um studios
uh run you know as we were developing
the the movie with matt
it became clear to us early on i think
matt was the first to bring it up
um that in order to really do this story
justice because we wanted to make it
as much as we were capable a story from
the iraqi point of view that's why we
looked out
looked for great creative collaborators
like muhammad
people who could bring become our
partners in this process on a creative
level
to help us translate the story from a
very specifically iraqi point of view
and the actors were great partners with
us as that in that as well
and early on before any of them got
involved
matt said he really thought that this
movie needed to be told in arabic and
that as soon as he said it joe and i
were like yes of course you're right
because
that's the only way we can really sort
of run run at
that experience the best way we can run
at that experience rather than having to
translate it to english or have the
actors speak in english so
we we looked very hard throughout the
arabic speaking world for
for actors um and look
it was joe and i were coming off of our
run at marvel this was the first movie
that we decided to
produce and finance through our our new
new company agbo
and a lot of our philosophy in
filmmaking is sort of
what can you do what can you contribute
to the process of cinema
that is unique to you unique to your
voice unique to your capabilities
there's not a lot of people that could
have made a movie like this in the
arabic language if any
you know i don't know this this movie
would have been made this way anywhere
else
other than agbo but we are in a really
unique position that we had had a lot of
success
and that we could sort of push a
difficult movie through the system
that other people may not be able to get
through the system and we looked at it
as our privilege and our opportunity and
our responsibility to do that on this
movie yeah listen i'm actually really
grateful you made this because
there's a lot going on in iraq that i
think people see on the news
they hear about in the newspapers but
until you see it visually
in a movie like this where you see
what's really being depicted
um i think this is much easier for
people to get to understand
what people are sacrificing and what's
going on on that side of the world
to wake up to war every day of your life
again that's what i was talking about
earlier is
there's a perspective shift here and you
have to use the word privilege and we're
a very privileged nation
um and it is important i think look
there's one thing that
um digital distributors are doing is
that they're
they're allowing more international
stories to be told
because they can target international
audiences more specifically
um we're able to you know utilize um
in indian caste uh in in significant
ways in extraction uh
and reach the indian audience in a very
specific way perhaps
in a way that we might not have been
able to theatrically uh
and i think um uh it's allowing
more international stories to be told as
i said earlier
we have responsibility in media to keep
widening the perspective
away from a hollywood anglo-centric
uh perspective uh something i normally
don't single out someone's performance
when i'm talking
to i just normally don't do it but i
rewatched the movie last night
and i believe you pronounce his name
suhail he is
absolutely commanding the screen in this
movie he is
fantastic what is your reaction
obviously
you know in the casting process you
never really know how it's going to go
but what was it like for you guys seeing
dailies or
or seeing him because he is spectacular
in this
yeah i mean i remember right from his
eye it was it was uh his audition
where that revelation really first came
to us and
i mean his story is remarkable i mean he
is part of that iraqi diaspora
who had to flee the country because of
difficult conditions because of
oppressive conditions that were specific
to them and their families
and he ended up in america i think it
was in new mexico and just sort of
working in a
i think it was an old age home you know
um in the kitchen
and here's this amazing actor who
despite his training in iraq you know
because of the those social conditions
and those political conditions ended up
in a very far away place
with far different opportunities and it
was you know
when to realize that we had this
opportunity
to not only find him but then cast him
in this role i mean that was
part of the miracle of what this movie
was it's sort of in a way
it was a a way to sort of counteract
some of the trauma that's happened to
that culture because of the wars that
have happened there and i think stu
sue hale's experience is a perfect
example of that remarkable actor
who was not working as an actor
and also if i'm not mistaken you guys
put him in cherry after
being in this yeah and he's got a cameo
and cherry i mean we
he's one of the best actors that we've
ever worked with and it
as aunt said his story is um
uh is both tragic and inspiring that
this incredibly talented actor
did not have a forum in which he could
share his gifts
uh and we couldn't be more proud of his
performance in the film i think it's
it's an oscar-worthy performance i guess
talk a little bit about the editing room
and we're working with matthew uh
because obviously this is his
first feature um did you guys have to
like struggle with a much longer cut
were there you know things that you
discovered in the editing room that you
had to solve
no i think because he's a writer he was
incredibly efficient
uh and the first cut of the movie was
excellent um
you know this is a very specific mission
film
you know there's there's not a lot of
room to breathe by design
uh it's meant to be relentless it's
meant to drop you into
the um you know incredibly
um dramatic and painful
uh days that people in mosul experience
every single day of their life and
and he captured that um uh and and his
first coat was actually he's a very
emotional artist matthew and he throws
himself
wholeheartedly uh into everything he
does
um that's a shame we couldn't get
muhammad on here but muhammad
worked as a creative partner with
matthew because matthew was so
passionate about telling the story and
he wanted to maintain
authenticity to the last detail
muhammad is is the you know most
renowned filmmaker
in iraq and uh muhammad came to work
with matthew on the film
and they've fostered a partnership that
allowed the movie i think to um
to stay um as true and realistic as
possible
before i run out of time with you guys i
do want to ask um the other day it came
out
that uh basically streaming it's clearly
the future
uh it's a it's a um it's huge obviously
this is coming out on netflix
um and it just came out that you know
wonder woman is going to get released on
hbo max and in theaters and disney plus
is releasing their big pixar movie
seoul on and both are actually coming
out on christmas day on uh you know
disney plus
what's your take on you know wonder
woman going to
hbo max i mean i i think patty jenkins
said it best is that
she made something that um that she put
an incredible amount of love and joy
into
and now she's ready to share it with the
world and you know
circumstances are dictating that you
know
options for people to view things uh are
are best that certain people will want
to see it in the theater and other
people
for health reasons might need to see it
at home um
and i think i think it's incredibly
brave and bold of her as a filmmaker
um but i i do think that this is the
future
of the business is that there can be
room for both digital
and theatrical and in fact both could
perhaps enhance each other's
um business and experience um but
you know there are lots of people that
around the world that have
greater access to digital than they do
with theater um
and and this is just one way to to reach
those people so as an artist
if you want to get the most eyeballs i
think that
a joint theatrical digital um play
is uh is an incredible way to do that
yeah i think it's going to bring a lot
of new eyeballs and subscribers to hbo
max to
this movie oh 100 but i actually i want
to touch on you guys have a great
relationship with netflix
and uh i i am like obviously you guys
have had great success with the avengers
movies at the worldwide box office
making billions of dollars
but like with something like extraction
which is i think
netflix's biggest movie that they've
released their biggest original movie
is it nice to sort of be able to not
worry about your opening weekend box
office
and just make something that you are
proud of and it just goes out there and
you don't have to worry about it after
yeah i mean i think that it's part of it
it's become a cultural problem
that uh that we define the success of a
film by its opening weekend box office
that um not all movies have built to
um to blow the doors off uh um
with uh with gowdy numbers the way that
the avengers films are
uh and you know i think perhaps the best
thing and the greatest gift that
netflix and and other digital
distributors have given to artists is
that they have obscured that metric
right that metric is no longer important
they've made it irrelevant
and so stories can be told and it really
just becomes about the audience's
response to those stories
um it's not about any sort of system
built around it i.e you know it's box
office how did it do those stories
um um you know it's not it's not about
some critical aggregate
it was literally about how is the
audience responding the story
and they can find it if they want to and
you know like i said there are people
that those stories can reach in
different ways who
who might not have access to
the theater or it's more cost effective
for them because they can share an
account
with other people and everyone can
afford the
ticket to a theater the same way that
that again that we can here in the u.s
so
um i think uh i think it's uh
you know it's disruptive in a very
healthy way
i think that one of the things about
netflix is that they
you can you don't have to release a four
quadrant movie you can aim at
that specific audiences with netflix
because of their worldwide reach
can you of just sort of talk about your
relationship with netflix
and um what you're looking forward to uh
doing with them
when you're trying to do something
that's new and disruptive which is
what joe and i so the reason we formed
our new company
is for that exact purpose you know we
like being pushed by technology
we like being pushed into new areas we
like the new possibilities that are
become available in terms of how you
reach audiences this is stuff we feed
off of
um and feeds our creative process
so the idea that that netflix is kind of
like the wild west
you know it's a new format they're still
in the experimental phase of figuring
out
what works how their system works how
they connect with audiences
so it's really nice to be partners with
them at this moment
in their growth arc because there's all
kinds of possibilities for filmmakers
and they've been a very um open partner
with us
they've been very creatively supportive
of what we want to do and i think that
speaks to the fact that they
are themselves in an experimental
mindset in terms of what works on their
platform
and what the possibilities are are on
their platform
um so it's yeah it's amazing partnership
for filmmakers
on that note i i really do encourage
everyone who's watched this interview
to watch mosul it is a fantastic movie i
really commend you guys for making it
and i really hope that uh the world
watches it because it's really really
really well done thank you thank you
um cool you guys good luck with the rest
of the day and i'm sure we will talk
soon
goodbye